America shares strong alliance with  North Korea VP Harris says White House  plays damage control the White House  appears to have removed Harris's mention  of North Korea in an official transcript  Harris mistakenly made the claim during  her first trip to the demilitarized zone  separating North and South Korea this  week let's play the video here for you  guys so the United States  shares a very important relationship  which is an alliance  and it is an alliance that is strong and  enduring  here's why this is important right we I  mentioned we brushed on this but I got  to bring it up because the deeper issue  here is  I've often ragged on Joe Biden for  saying Libya when he meant Syria and the  danger of misspeaking is to public  capacity yeah there are people around  the world who just heard this and I  wonder what impact that will have on a  lot of things